we told you earlier Wall Street took a
hit today the new the news of the
terrorists from China took it pretty
hard the president's press spokesman
says President Trump will fight back it
is the latest salvo in the Grodin
growing trade dispute which some feel
could lead to an all-out trade war among
the world's two largest economies of
course mana rich Edson has the latest
tonight from the State Department China
the world's largest port consumer last
year American pig farmers sold nearly
700 million dollars of their pork to
China China just announced that same
meat will be 25% more expensive we
export more than 26% of all US pork
production outside of our borders so any
disruption to an important market like
China is bad news for us hog farmers
China's Ministry of Commerce says it is
imposing tariffs on 128 American
products sold in China pushing up the
price of those goods and presenting a
substantial disadvantage to American
manufacturers and farmers China
announced a 15 percent tariff on u.s.
fruit wine steel pipes and other
products 120 in total and a 25% import
fee on eight others like pork and
recycled aluminum this is in response to
Trump administration tariffs on aluminum
and steel imports from China and other
countries the white house justifies
those tariffs claiming they'll address
the annual 350 billion dollar US trade
deficit with China he's tired of us
being taken advantage of they've taken
our intellectual property and the
president's gonna fight back and he's
gonna push back but we want to be able
to work with him to make sure that we're
getting a good deal and that we're not
taking a bit advantage of it China says
it's tariffs hit about three billion
dollars worth of American imports a
small percentage of the more than 130
billion dollars in goods the United
States sends to China though analysts
and free trade advocates say they worry
about the next step president Trump has
also threatened to tax sixty billion
dollars in Chinese imports in response
to China's theft of American trade
secrets the US government says that
costs us businesses between 225 and 600
billion dollars a year discussions
continue between the government's
American producers say they want the US
and China to resolve this soon there are
five hundred and fifty thousand jobs in
America that are tied directly to the
u.s. pork industry a hundred and ten
thousand of those jobs are directly tied
to exports so important for the growth
of our industry and for our economy
there are also national security
concerns China is key to upcoming talks
with North Korea and the white house has
just announced the president Trump will
soon meet with the leader of a top
competitor in the region for China
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
they'll discuss North Korea's strategy
Brett
Richardson live of the State Department
rich thang